[Music]
in dry spell Muse oh yes do with sex huh
submitted by
bruised banana Oh
oh my god lens camera lens yes so if you
guys saw something blurry it was just a
spider [ __ ]
oh it's just living going about to kill
that [ __ ] oh oh it'll be dead
like that I'll crush him into oblivion
like yeah nevian here are six things
that happened to men's bodies when they
don't have sex for a while I need to
know because I never get sex you married
about if I jack off oh that's different
than not jacking off yeah is there
actually six things that happen to men's
body if they don't ejaculate and it's
blue ball syndrome real or you need to
feel the warmth of a woman's bosom or
possum possum
I think masturbating it's not the table
I think it also kept the ejaculation
thing okay number one your rhythm gets
thrown off the next time you have sex so
we're not that old expression if you
don't use it you lose it so science
suggests that to a degree that might be
true so there was a study back in 2008
in the American Journal of Medicine and
it concluded that men in their 50s 60s
and 70s that weren't sexually active
were more likely to suffer from erectile
dysfunction and so and so they're saying
that you know there's a while that you
don't go with if you don't have sex for
a while then you're just your entire
body kind of forgets a little bit how
sex works and then you struggle oh it's
the Alps for me if I haven't gone for a
while and I ejaculate pretty quick the
next time I'm like maybe it's for older
guys
it might be like 10 years of like
jacking off or touching it even or
whatever that's like having a dead ass
arm I don't [ __ ] move this
[ __ ] for like 30 years it's
gonna be very skinny and not useful you
look at 30 years man like is this 30
years they don't know that's like put it
if you stop playing the guitar all of
sudden you're rusty and I think that
you're still young so you still got a
lot to start your own but if you're like
50 or 60 if you're not activated as a
starter on this primal way so then this
is only talking about boner town nothing
this is published I am mental calm I
read this thing on men's health doctor
long ago where a dude will try to figure
out what would happen to you if you
don't masturbate and that [ __ ]
said I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna try
this out that [ __ ] lasted three days it
was just dude on men's health or now
music article there's a no Jack
challenge
oh no no not November is it it's Alice I
was no-shave November and then no night
so you get both ways because I can't
grow a beard and our jacked off plenty
of times and did it so number two check
if you don't masturbate your risk of
prostate cancer goes up that one I heard
about that one why God for the health
but what if you masturbate too much I'm
not sure about too much but they are
saying that is too much
I think it's cool cuz your unclogging
the pipes yeah yeah so they're saying
that oh it's a dead [ __ ] in the pipes
right you gotta just expel so yeah nice
thing that there have been multiple
studies that have pointed to the
conclusion that high ejaculation
frequency which is about four point six
to seven times a week is linked to lower
yeah it's linked to lower prostate
cancer who has time other than [ __ ]
teenagers in like [ __ ] junk kids to
do it that often
you could jack off every day we wake up
in the morning right the shower just
knock it out
I think I'm looking at I'm booking
tonight they don't take my dick out in
the Navy so like okay hey what you guys
is records when you guys were teenagers
for like in a day trav like a track
quick not me like I know in a day like
when me you're just boring but I've
probably done him more than five times
yeah I'm lower than that yeah I was like
four and I was like it doesn't nothing
else happen anymore like you can't do
any more I've never I've never done it
that profuse leemaster probably like
somewhere between 16 and 19 I was not
still living in my dad's house I was
just really that bored and it was to the
point where it hurts yeah yeah still
counts
I don't know why I guess I have nothing
else to do so I'm just gonna jack off
once again and then I feel like guilty
and shameful that I did that when it's
already hurting and it's just clear
liquid coming out at this point but I
was like one more time you jerk off and
you feel like you're decorated but then
nothing comes out yeah what were what
like like huge and nothing comes out
yeah yeah you don't worry you don't
ejaculate you just nothing comes out all
right it'll do that yeah yeah what
you're saying where it's like clear
liquid to this but it's all am I still a
little bit comes out but it's like
nothing is like pre-cum amounts yeah
yeah yeah I've never dyed all that
myself i jacked off like it was a
[ __ ] Olympic sport dude I was trained
for that [ __ ] cuz I was preparing for
the future I said to myself I need to be
able to last long for the woman of my
dreams
right cuz I I got a yeah she [ __ ]
hurt it's hurting and it's driving like
back to back to back earlier just in a
date and it's worse than a day not back
to back to back but listen man there was
a very healthy supply of porn and the
supply just didn't meet the man or the
demand yeah the demand all those supply
yes
[ __ ] anomic understand economics do is
too many cuz I was already like [ __ ]
when can i recharge to watch the next
one because there's just too many in the
library have you guys ever tried this so
you know like for most guys after you
come it's really sensitive and you can't
touch it again and it's like oh like a
wilted flower have you guys ever right
after go [ __ ] that I'm gonna wake your
ass up and try to make sure slapping
them back hard again yeah yeah I've done
it for that sometimes you can keep it
you know if you try hard enough if you
do it there's a there's a window of like
a mini and you can like keep your heart
I swear you have a [ __ ] journal huh
no I got a good movie but I did
masturbate at a very very young age so
like it was kind of weird for me because
when I was younger I used to do it but
then nothing came out cuz I was like
that HBO fake porn thing where it was
like softcore we can't see anything but
you knew something was going on yeah um
so at age 12 I think I was doing my
thing and I was like oh [ __ ] what is
this stuff coming out and I was like
this one my dad told me about like this
is how babies are made and I was like
yeah that means I can't have like kids
now and I was like I got scared it was
like 12 or 11 I was me tonight freaked
out the first time when I was like yo
he's real now I remember that no it was
like clear liquid coming out first or
nothing at all my grandma had this like
neck massaging thing it was kind of like
a scarf but you you turn it on and it's
like dude and then [ __ ] massages your
neck that should I wrapped around my
[ __ ] dick and turned it on and that
was the worst and I don't know why I'm
like I don't we grab I'll take your bag
you put it back right now I didn't even
know what I was doing but that [ __ ] was
soaked in my [ __ ] like not even ready
come juice and I was like [ __ ] around
with it and I didn't know what I was
doing it just felt good
no I was [ __ ] oh you should that be an
awesome [ __ ] YouTube video no be
awesome vlog rippin wait till Tiger you
got some vlog I'm not thinking of talk
of dick advisee no no my caster get up
I'll do it
checking up on your kind of cute come on
point number three he can't control his
head like trying really hard look carrot
figures he's just she's just scrunching
it up number three your blood pressure
can spike if you stop having sex really
angry all the time
well they're saying that um you're
stressed yeah yeah so they're saying
that in a 2006 study in the medical
journal biological psychology they found
that people who are having regular sex
had lower levels of blood pressure than
those what's regular sex I don't know
okay alright and that might all be like
subjective I know they're say my regular
like just like you constantly oh I did
weather weekly monthly whatever but if
you're on some sort of talk schedule
yeah [ __ ] schedule
alright number four if you don't have
sex for a long time you will get more
stressed out yeah of course I don't
think I need I think that's their
everybody yep next one number five your
immune system gets weaker Wow [ __ ] so
they are saying that there was a study
where they asked patients who were
having sex once or twice a week to
provide saliva samples those samples
were found to contain an extremely high
concentration of the common cold busting
antibody immunoglobulin globulin 8 and
so they're just saying that it helps you
fight off a better immune systems Oh
that's it thanks a lot G oh look at him
now he never wants it you didn't give me
enough blow jobs
I need any blow jobs I just have to take
it from him
yeah take what from him do you have to
take I'll take his dick for me yeah
that's good for me I do but look at how
big he is that's how you train so hard
so I can't freakin take advantage of him
anymore
doesn't matter how big about you [ __ ]
stop it doesn't matter how big of guy is
you tickle his balls he'll melt and the
[ __ ] tree of life grows tree ma yeah
and so the last point here number six
your work performance might slip of
course yeah do you that's it that's all
you got ha because all stress
everything's related to one thing stress
stress stress stress when she relieve
the stress oh and also your work
performance goes lower because when a
guy comes he comes to his senses it's
true that's right after you come you
[ __ ] come in the girls play she's like
why did I do that to you that's ghost
and you're like how graceful I should
have never done so you come that song
plays in your head I know but you guys
are like Neanderthals like you guys are
like we are Homo sapiens or literally
animals I don't get all scientific
primate I'm just trying to make a point
how you think what how you guys just
didn't evolve the way women did that's
all yeah
what crazy crazy not your [ __ ] wants
to call your pheromones [ __ ]
wait what about it your pheromones send
it out what about it and that makes the
guys go crazy it's crazy juice yeah yeah
if you guys should have crazy juice
everywhere it will really mean yes I
stopped my ball girls yeah it's not my
fault that girl's got a nice butt
[Music]